-Making their US TV debut,
performing the title track to
their debut album,
"The Overload,"
give it up for Yard Act!
♪♪
-Just you and me.
Woo!
♪♪
♪ I'm shaking up my eight ball
'cause I'm trying to see ♪
♪ What tomorrow's world has got
in store for me ♪
♪ Your freedom
don't come cheap ♪
♪ I'm bartering hard
with no room to give ♪
♪ Living my life as if my head
ain't a complete sieve ♪
♪ Hold your horses,
bandage up its bloodied knees ♪
♪ Poor thing's
been exhausted since '83 ♪
♪ But from the causeway
it's hard to see ♪
♪ The full extent
of the damage ♪
♪ You couldn't see
the woods for the trees ♪
♪ Good Lord,
how am I supposed to cope? ♪
♪ In the age
of the gentrified savage ♪
-♪ There's no hope ♪
-♪ Kids these days they think
they've been hard done by ♪
♪ But they've never even
looked at an iron lung ♪
♪ Like I did once ♪
♪ They've got the whole thing
wrong, just bumbling along ♪
♪ On the bottom rung,
knocking boots ♪
♪ And huffing designer bongs ♪
♪ What you've got's
a constant hit ♪
♪ It's not worth
what they paying for it ♪
♪ In my day, the gear on
the street was so weak ♪
♪ It could eat your ambition
in a matter of weeks ♪
♪ Just tryna envision the peak,
and that's bleak ♪
♪ And that's bleak ♪
♪ The overload of discontent ♪
♪ The constant burden
of making sense ♪
♪ It won't relent,
it won't repent ♪
♪ How to remain in dissonance ♪
♪ The overload of discontent ♪
♪ The constant burden
of making sense ♪
♪ It won't relent,
it won't repent ♪
♪ How to remain in dissonance ♪
Oh, Jesus.
-You like that, Graham?
-Oh, now then.
♪ Look here, what you need
to understand is ♪
♪ If you wanna make
some decent money from it ♪
♪ You'd be better off kicking ♪
♪ That dickhead singer
you've got in out the band ♪
♪ And getting yourself
a gig down The Grand ♪
♪ I know the landlord,
Fat Andy ♪
♪ And I bet he'd be up
for giving you a leg up ♪
♪ If you just give him a hand ♪
♪ Just don't be
doing originals ♪
♪ Play the standards,
don't get political ♪
♪ I know what
that dickhead singer's like ♪
♪ He'll end up
in the back of the ambulance ♪
♪ With the mic stand rammed up
his ass twice over ♪
♪ All 'cause he couldn't ignore
the flag and be polite ♪
♪ Show some respect
and listen to my advice ♪
♪ 'Cause if you don't
challenge me on anything ♪
♪ You'll find
I'm actually very nice ♪
♪ America, are you listening? ♪
♪ I'm actually relly nice ♪
♪ The overload of discontent ♪
♪ The constant burden
of making sense ♪
♪ It won't relent,
it won't repent ♪
♪ How to remain in dissonance ♪
♪ The overload of discontent ♪
♪ The constant burden
of making sense ♪
♪ It won't relent,
it won't repent ♪
♪ How to remain in dissonance ♪
♪ The overload of discontent ♪
♪ The constant burden
of making sense ♪
♪ It won't relent,
it won't repent ♪
♪ How to remain ♪
♪ How to remain in dissonance ♪
♪ How to remain now, woo! ♪
♪♪